hey guys welcome to reality check and to
Cologne Germany why well because it's
time for part three of our exploration
into PC graphics terms and what they
actually mean so I've come to the
spiritual home of graphics Germany
that's right the very first pixel was
actually discovered right here in
Cologne okay that's not true but
actually one of the earliest uses of the
word pixel is in German and it's build
punk'd which literally means picture
point so this is that okay so I'm also
here because of Gamescom but there's no
chance that's getting in the way of me
bringing you guys this week's reality
check for me post-processing is the
ultimate I'm gonna take this but I'm
almost certain I have no idea what its
gonna do but and you know what it's
actually difficult to see exactly what
post-processing is because it can mean a
whole lot of different things as their
name suggests though it applies effects
after the initial render this means they
can work on the whole frame as one image
rather than the individual objects which
has its advantages
so what effects are we talking about
this is great for making movement feel
more fast or natural for example racing
games use this effect heavily to create
that feeling of breakneck speed first
person shooters also use it but to
simulate realistic movement and how the
human eye gathers that information both
bloom and HDR attempt to make light seem
more dynamic by realistically simulating
the way the human eye or a camera
experiences light for example both
replicate the over brightness the human
eye experiences when moving from a dark
space to a brightly lit one like
emerging from a deep dark dungeon into
the sunlight for example so what's the
difference then well HDR is basically
bloom plus it's smarter arguably gives
better results but is also more
processor intensive
invidious physics as the name implies
alters game world physics when it's
turned on players can interact with
objects that have gravitational
properties
knocking throwing pulling and pushing
them want to give it a blast Mirror's
Edge and Borderlands 2 are filled with
boxes to knock over and flappy things to
shoot at with your guns such physics so
why do we even need things like physics
well simulating real-world physics is
fiendishly complicated there just so
many damn variables so game designers
have to come up with fancy algorithms to
simulate specific physics things like
ragdoll effects and Max Payne specific
car handling in games like Forza
Motorsport 5 of course - Raiders
infamous stress effects my clients often
ask me how do I get that salon look my
hair without it turning into a solid
Ligon alum I tell them the answer is
simple tress-fx max graphic shampoo
guaranteed to fight the seven signs of
aliasing trash effects is a real-time
hair physics system and while the
intended effect isn't always spot-on
Lara's hair fluttering in the wind and
reacting to her quick movements can at
times look super impressive but you know
what understanding hair physics is
surprisingly complicated for example
scientists recently came up with an egg
Nobel Prize winning equation to explain
the real-life physics of a ponytail now
this might sound kind of absurd but
predicting the behavior of a ponytail is
really difficult due to the various
factors involved including this
stiffness of hair fibers the effects of
gravity and even the presence of curly
or wavy hair can drastically change the
shape of a ponytail so yeah I think
dress effects does a pretty good job all
things considered
okay well that's about all the graphics
terms we had left this has been a
slightly shorter but significantly more
German episode of the show
so make sure you check back next week
for more reality check
au revoir bon giorno Asahi